لان معنا الان نترككم مع هذه الصور
المباشره من مدينه سانتوس بولايه السا
وباولو بالبرازيل دي مراسم دفني جوهره كره
القدم بيلي بعد ان اتيحت الفرصه لمحبيه
خلال ساعات الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه
لالقاء نظره الوداع الاخيره على جثمانه
على ملعب نادي سانتوس اول نادي لعب له في
مستهلي حياته
الكرويه وكان له من الانجازات ما همم لم
يسبقه اليه احد في البرازيل وقطعا في نادي
سانتوس احد اشهر الانديه واكبر الانديه
البرازيليه وعلى الصعيد العالمي عندما
ابتدائنا بالاقليم طبعا هو حصل على كاس
امريكا اللاتينيه مع منتخب بلاده وهذا على
كاس العالم اللاعب الوحيد الذي تمكن من
فعل ذلك تقريبا ثلاث مرات مع منتخبه في
اول مره كانت وما زال عمره 17 عاما
هذه صور اذن تاتينا كما قلت من مراسم
تشييع
بيلي الذي يعتبر ايقونه من البرازيل
وقد فعل لكره القدم ما لم يفعله احد من
قبل لعل محبي الرياضه ومتابعي كره القدم
شاهد ذلك الفيديو الذي يظهر كثير من
مهارات كره القدم وقد بداها قبل اي احد ثم
شاهدناها تكرر مع اساطير كره القدم التي
تلته مثل ااا رونالدو
ميسي الكثيرون لم يتمكنوا ولم تكن لهم
فرصه مشاهده وهو يلعب كره القدم ولكن اكيد
شاهدوا همم الكثير من المقاطع
المصوره له يستمر النقاش حتى هذه اللحظه
عامه اذا كان هو اعظم لاعب في تاريخ كره
القدم منذ بدايتها ام اخرون مثل دييغو
ارماندو مارادونا او ليونيل همم ميسي
ويضيف البعض طبعا اسماء اخرى مثل رونالدو
الظاهره وكريستيانو رونالدو هذه هي صور
للبرازيليين
انتظروني همم القاء النظره الاخيره على
النعش بيليه قبل ان ينقل بعد ذلك الى منزل
العائله وسيشارك في مراسم الدفن افراد
العائله همم فقط نعلم ان وزير والدته التي
تبلغ من العمر 92 عاما ما زالت همم على
قيد الحياه
[تصفيق]
بيبو
صدام
[تصفيق]